what's up fellow good humans welcome to
another episode of odd man huh we want
to feature you and an intro so stick
around till after the video to find out
the rules enjoying the meanwhile I see
so many people who are using government
assistance to go to Disneyland that's
not what it's for it's so that you can
make America great again we brought
together 7 Trump supporters I am a Trump
supporter I am a Trump supporter I am a
Trump supporter I am a Trump supporter I
am a trump supporter I'm a Trump
supporter I am a Trump supporter
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is they'll split a cash prize
[Music]
if the liar survives he or she wins the
entire prize
I think we should say why we support him
it's assuming we all do so did you want
to start sure I'm supporting because I'm
a dad I support him because record our
unemployment rate stuff like that when
people lie they tend to like touch their
face I really love how he's a Christian
and he loves Jesus and God he's actually
a the only president in history this
party because he follows the
Constitution I support him because I
feel like we have more religious freedom
with him in office and Hillary yeah
there's so many reasons but America
first I guess is the reason it's my
reason it seems her so she was right
next to me and should necessarily cut me
off but she seemed just very nervous she
didn't sound like she believed what she
was telling everybody okay my faith
informs my voting simple as that and
second my dad has been in Marine Corps
for 30 years and so that support is
really important to me it was super
nerve-wracking going into the first
speed round because you know that
everyone has assumptions about how you
look he's got a lot of diversity of
support out there they just don't speak
up out of fear and so it was interesting
to try to read everything from body
language to what they were actually
saying I voted for Sierra in the first
round I thought she was well because of
her look her dyed hair and how she
initiated the conversation I think it
was the combination of my nerves and
because I was wearing the crop top and
it's not so conservative and I had a
piercing out earlier
if you have any doubt and you would like
to continue the game
everybody's gonna vote in 2020 yes
absolutely does everybody have a
favorite for 2020 I'm voting for Trump I
don't know yet
yeah I'm proud to cast my vote for
Donald Trump president Trump yes Trump
here I think I made people focus on me
because I didn't know if I don't know if
I would vote for him again I think that
if someone better does come along I
don't want to just automatically say
he'll forever have my vote I just want
to clarify doesn't kiss you guys don't
think that I support him because they
totally do but I am curious that one of
the major things right now is
immigration so what is your guys's
stance on immigration well I'm a
second-generation American on both sides
so my dad's parents immigrated from
India and my mom's from Mexico so I
think this country would be nothing
without immigrants at all yeah I grew up
in California in Los Angeles California
I've seen the demographics change and
not often for the good you know there
are many homeless Americans and veterans
they're homeless on the streets and yet
we spend tons of taxpayer money to
support illegal immigration of you know
we have a constitution and if you can't
respect our laws yeah it's better that
you don't come Keith you know he was a
trump supporter it flowed where do you
get your news I don't watch any cable
news at all I listen to a lot of
podcasts like more specifically like Joe
Rogan because he usually has people like
ben shapiro and steven crowder along
with people who like are more leftist
you see Alex Jones on Joe Rogan I think
he's like wild so that's why I get my
most of my information from if the wars
and Alex Jones these are really informed
people here you got it you got to be on
top of your game if you're gonna never
talk about politics of anybody if you
want to know the truth you have to look
at both sides to understand you know
maybe he's just introverted but to me he
didn't seem like he was actively engaged
in the conversation I vote about mic
because I wanted to assume that not all
white men are Trump supporters I was
thinking it was the first person I said
oh she's
already so what am I just make it more
difficult for me now it's wondering how
the silence was gonna play
I now know so like what would you say to
the people who are gonna think
negatively of you as a trump supporter
well I think the first thing is that no
matter what side you stand on president
Trump has reinvigorated our democratic
process you know they say well he's a
racist
I said well you just ask them the people
who believe that you say well what's
racist about his policies just because
of my support it discredit who I am as a
person or like they're not willing to
listen because it's like yeah it's
really yeah in college because I'm
pro-life
I'm discredited from everything so oh
you're Catholic you can't have an
opinion on this we already know what
your opinion is gonna be so it's like we
could talk about it we don't need to
fight about it just have a conversation
the your next-door neighbor it probably
supports Trump and you don't know how is
given the power back to the people you
know the elites have held it for so long
and there's they're still fighting to
like keep you know stay in power but I
think it's really divine and you know
Todd's ham is in it Jesus Christ
I have a question probably for the next
segment if we have another one all right
Zach made himself seem too suspicious
because he had his American pin flag I
thought maybe he was trying too hard
honestly I yeah I was kind of baffled by
it I wasn't really surprised just
because like I don't fit the the look of
somebody who supports Trump I think I
voted for Zack because I didn't want to
vote for Natalie which is probably why I
voted for Trump I didn't wanna bring so
I voted for Trump I of course you know
I'm I'm curious you know because you
know obviously you guys are like the
Millennial age how do you define
conservatism the current narrative of
the left is creating a sort of
victimhood and what I find on the right
is that there's a huge Victor mentality
it's all how much how hard do you want
to work to get your life to a certain
point I wouldn't even use like the label
for myself even registered I'm
independent it's deregulation and
providing the opportunity for everyone
to make the best for themselves not to
be provided the best not to have
oversight financially so that you're
obligated to someone else because my dad
came from absolutely nothing did did his
national duty and built a life for
himself and I was able to go to college
because of it like I went to school on
the GI Bill from him they see so many
people who are using government
assistance to go to Disneyland that's
not what it's for it's so that you can
build yourself up and make America great
again it's like if I'm gonna work and my
dad's gonna work the hours that he does
and not be home so that he can provide
for his family
it's only fair that he gets to see that
money just really quickly because I know
his route is gonna end so you said that
you wouldn't necessarily or not for sure
casting your vote for Trump in 2020 is
there again if you had a vote for a
Democratic candidate right now as of
right now I don't see that person okay
but I just I'm not sure I support him
now as a president and in 2016 I just
it's not to say that I wouldn't it's
just whoever
she talked a lot more than Katherine did
so there's a lot more opportunity for me
to like find holes I didn't want to put
anybody out I just felt like everyone
was honest and so I was just like I
don't even think mike is still in the
game but I wrote his name I really
thought I was I don't consider myself a
Republican in any way all of my
positions are pretty progressive I'm
super happy to have this dialogue I
think this experience has taught me that
a lot of the people who are Trump
supporters like Ciaran for example go
back and forth on what they believe and
are asking themselves tough questions
everyone like has a story to tell and
everyone's voices should be heard even
if they disagree with you what's up Kate
human thank you for watching thanks so
much for watching if you guys want to be
in one of our intros for the episodes in
the next 48 hours put a story on
Instagram telling us why you love
odd-man-out so much tag Jubilee media
we're gonna feature the best one in an
inch
so your face can be in front of millions
who knows anyways thanks for watching
we'll see you around and we hope to see
your face soon we do here on thanks